a questa giornata bella ciao non
[Musica]
fa dj originals
oggi lavoro
io ho avuto la fortuna che il mio canale
youtube è decollato subito che avevo 17
anni per la mente sono dieci anni che
faccio questo lavoro nappi non ho mai
fatto quella gavetta che fanno un po
tutti quanti no nel mondo del lavoro che
fanno anche gli youtube era volta
insomma e quindi oggi siamo qua a
cantina meridionale cantina meridionale
è un ristorante di milano che ha appena
aperto le sante nemico alfonso dove
abbiamo mangiato anche la pizza con gli
insetti io che sono scordinato come una
lontra morta oggi servirò ai tavoli
quindi ci faremo briffare da alfonso
subito questo quale l'essere guido
mafia tutti grazie a questa è la vetta
di nessuno che ti devi mettere per fare
il cameriere noi si mettessero è infatti
l'azione che dal controllo allora
spiega mi tutto lì per como della tavola
l'auto latex materia di porti meno poi
devi tornare dopo mezz'ora di ci avete
scelto noi ci son dimenticati parla
ravissimo e torni a quelle ordinazioni
di what i do il blocchetto con la penna
tulle finirono senza gara vivere
l'ultimo scritto al liceo e questa è una
cosa che non so fa ci può portare
l'acqua io quel bicchiere che è un
piatto non c'è bisogno di metterlo per
fortuna ma lo sente più sicuro tieni con
due maglie di con due mari hanno finito
di mangiare gli togli il piatto
mandolino gli piatto che cosa gli dite
sono iscritti al canale si rifanno
napoli soprattutto che mi danno la
mancia alla fine solo quando mangiano i
camerieri ci hanno lanciato corpo e io
so street
prima di cominciare ragazzi con questo
video medico volevo informarvi che lo
sponsor di oggi è di young youth of four
e l'exchange centopercento italiano tra
i più forti in crescita in tutta europa
che si prova le l'obiettivo di rendere
facile e veloce il mercato delle cripto
valute e dei 23 ai meno esperti per
farlo hanno creato un eco sistema molto
completo perché c'è young platform step
che è un'applicazione dove all'interno
c'è una sorta di wikipedia gratuita che
chiamata accademiche vi spiega tutte
quante le cose inoltre ragazzi
all'interno di stampe potete completare
obiettivi sfide anche solo camminando e
guadagnare così il loro token di young
che il fulcro centrale di tutto il loro
ecosistema è che vi è utilissimo
all'interno dell'orecchio change
dall'alto ragazzi all'interno riad
platform exchange trovate la funzione
salvadanaio con questa ragazzi volete
acquistare ricorrentemente le vostre
cripto valute preferite senza pensieri
ed infine ragazzi tramite il tuo che
young potete accedere
ci sono vari livelli dal bronzo al
platinum che offrono un sacco di
benefici se voi siete bravi bravi hanno
anche la versione pro se volete fare
trading su analisi tecnica vi registrate
su exchange i ragazzi con link che vi
lascio descrizione è effettuato un
deposito di almeno 50 euro avete subito
un bonus di 25
[Musica]
la gente si siede io che devo fare
portin venuto già
cominciamo bene noi
grazie state bisogno
quando arriva lo stipendio ragazzi prego
buonasera sono 66 i ragazzi
gennaro abbiamo un insalata di mare ok
fuoco fritto e madame che a volte non
devi dare la quella la vasta come diceva
branca senso ragazzi mangiano da notare
intanto che avevo piacere
pure fatto
che loro margherita punto tutto calato
di sales o no questo non avete messo il
menu anno posso
lascerò la tredicesima 2 posto ragazzi
di lingue buonissimo mi hanno fatto i
complimenti per il vino ma
le ordinazioni le prendo meno veloce
perché come non si capisce niente cioè
non riesco a capire sembrò quando i
medici prescrivono la tachipirina
paolo 22 arriva in sala dal secondo dai
[Musica]
signori
al
tavolo 22 all'interno tra di male la
cosa difficile per adesso e rapportarsi
con la gente ma perché sono introverso
io sennò sarebbe cioè per adesso non è
male quando tu nasci che ti danno la
tabella attributi da assegnare ogni
valore io ho proprio nell'interazione
sociale non ne ho messo neanche uno però
messo tutti intelligenza e carisma non è
la più grande
stronza l'anas ha derubato l'ultima per
cercare paghiamo di vetro picchiarci
grazie autonomi accendi la lampada bassa
intanto il piatto nel frattempo che vede
corso alte ma va che storia
è questa ed è una cosa sbagliata hai
portato il padre
che non ho mangiato fa missy ma un
minuto di pausa
dopo una meritatissima pausa di questi
trenta secondi che sto sfruttando
velocemente ho attivato anche la
funzione stand di young platform che ti
conta i passi sono fatti 2600 per adesso
mentre faccio avanti gli ato brevi
ristorante e questi passi li posso
convertire in una serie di servizi
sempre sull'app tra cui sconti sulle
commissioni dell'exchange oppure
convertibili anche in euro per
acquistare le vostre critiche c'è anche
la sezione quiz con domande e risposte
sulle tematiche cripto e nel caso di
risposte sbagliate potreste anche
utilizzare la sezione academy dove sono
presenti i consigli per educarsi al
meglio sulle tematiche cripto e block
chain e proprio grazie a step che vi
permette di muovere i primi passi nel
mondo del fritto in maniera semplice
perché lo fate camminando pure
completando queste sfide e quindi senza
fretta si diventa molto più consapevoli
del mondo delle clip quindi per muovere
i primi passi senza troppa paura insomma
di fare cose troppo in fretta hanno
fatto anche la serie critto attack con
giovanni muciaccia che spiega un sacco
di tematiche su questo mondo ma io non
me la posso guardare in questo momento
perché devo tornare al lavoro mi stanno
guardando male vado
non si può mettere a questa parte su
youtube ma due avevano una realta sono
hanno sbagliato mai avevo la pizza da
patatone più abusi così quella al arab a
non e sbagliato ad un po della
marciatori né
interi arrivo
i forti un'armatura ma senza servizio
che gli elettori st seedorf ha mangiato
ha
detto che mangiamo con la fredda
nella gara per me
questo ha portato tutto come era molto
buono
se volete qualcos'altro allora noi ci
abbiamo mai
quanto a struttura che scrivo così
[Musica]
possiamo chiedere il caffè teatro caffè
e basta si no ragazzi troppo facile mio
primo giorno mettetevi di fico pure
macchiato
scuse il primo giorno
anche all'ultimo
e quindi ragazzi tirando le somme di
quella che è stata la giornata devo dire
che mi è piaciuta parecchio come
esperienza anche se io sono molto
introverso come persona quindi non è
stato molto semplice ma se facessi un
lavoro del genere sempre a contatto con
il pubblico forse dopo un po inizierei a
sbloccarmi un po di più o forse iniziare
ad odiarli tutti quindi questa giornata
è finita incredibilmente senza danni e
stato e stato bellissimo lo ringrazio
volevo ringraziare niente platform
responsabilizzato questo video vi
ricordo che con il kin descrizione se
iscrivete è fate un deposito di almeno
50 euro avete un bonus di 25 oppure se
non siete utenti esperti potete
scaricare young platform stamp
gratuitamente io ti ringrazio per ogni
permesso di lavorare che è stata proprio
una cosa è avvertito no però è stata una
cosa formativa è stata che posso dirlo
ma solo quelli tradisce mai fatto
camerini neri e io ho fatto io perché
dice che chi non ha mai lavorato
stavolta elaborato a posti ci vediamo
adesso quando vai
siligardi che cosa che a chi pulisce ci
vediamo voglio capito ma io
ma finito il video
o
[Musica]
tante brizzante l'arbitro
dove l'acqua